The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So good
afternoon, once again.
And welcome back to
Computational Systems Biology,
lecture number seven.
And today we're going
to put to good use
two things that we have learned.
We've learned how to align high
throughput reads to genomes.
And we've learned how to take
a collection of high throughput
reads and assemble a genome.
And today we're going to
delve into the mysteries
of transcriptional regulation.
And so what I'd like to
discuss with you today
is a very important
set of techniques
that allows us to
elucidate exactly how genes
are regulated.
It's probably the most
important technique
for allowing us to
get at that question.
And I'm sure many of you
are familiar with the idea
of transcriptional
regulators, which
are proteins that bind in
a sequence specific way
to the genome and act
as molecular switches.
And we'll return to
some aspects of these
when we talk about
proteomics later in the term.
But suffice to
say, these proteins
have domains that interact
in a sequence specific way
with the DNA bases in one
of the grooves of DNA.
They also typically
contain a domain
which is an activation
domain or repression
domain that interacts
with other proteins that
can cause the genome to fold up.
And it can also help recruit
the RNA polymerase holoenzyme
to actually turn on
a gene transcription.
So here we have a
figure of a collection
of Pit1 molecules
interacting with the genome.
And of course, there are many
flavors of genomic regulators.
It's estimated that humans have
about 2,000 different proteins
that act as these molecular
switches, some as activators,
some as repressors.
And we're going to be
talking about, fundamentally,
today the idea of how
these molecules interact
with the genome and
control gene expression
through the analysis
of where they actually
interact with
specific genome loci.
So if we were to draw a
picture of how we understand
gene regulation in cartoon
form, if we have a gene here
with the transcription
start site
and we can imagine RNA
molecules being produced off
of this genomic
template, we know
that there are non-coding
regions of a gene that
permit for the binding
of these regulators.
And my definition
of a gene is all
of the DNA that's required to
make a specific transcriptive
protein.
So that includes not
only the coding parts
of the gene but the non-coding,
regulatory parts as well.
So we can imagine
out here that there
are a collection of
regulators, perhaps just
one, that bind to a sequence
that in turn activate
this gene, producing the RNA
transcript, which then in turn
this turned into
another protein.
This protein may
undergo some sort
of post-translational
modification
by signaling pathway or other
mechanism that activates it.
So regulators need
to be activated
before they could
bind and some do not.
And this activated regular
combine to get another gene
and cause another
RNA to be expressed.
And it may be, in
the second context,
that we need two
different proteins to bind
to activate the gene.
And so during the
course of the term,
we're going to be talking
about many aspects
of these regulatory networks,
including things like what
the regulatory code
of a genome is,
that is where these
binding sites are
and how they're occupied.
And we'll return to that
later on in today's lecture.
We'll talk about the dynamics of
binding of proteins, including
how concentration
[? they ?] dependent are.
And we'll talk about
combinatorial control,
whether or not,
for example, both
of these have to be
present or just one of them
needs to be present for
a gene to be transcribed,
and how you can use these
regulatory sequences
to implement very complex
computational functions.
But suffice to say, the
most important thing
that we have to identify
is the programming
that underlies the
genome, which includes
these regulatory sequences
and exactly how they're
occupied by regulatory proteins.
Ideally what we would
like to be able to do
is to do a single experiment
that elucidated all
of the regulatory
sites in the genome
and which ones were
occupied by which proteins.
But presently, that's
technically not possible.
So we'll begin today
with a technique that
allows us to consider
one protein at a time
and identify where it
occupies the genome.
Now there are other
kinds of proteins
that we can identify in terms
of where they are associated
with the genome that are not
transcriptional regulators, per
se.
For example, we all
know that chromatin
is organized on spools
called nucleosomes.
These nucleosomes are composed
of eight different histones
that have tails
on them, and there
can be covalent marks
put on these tails.
We'll return to this later on
when we talk about epigenetics.
But I did want to mention today
that it's possible to identify
where there are histones
with specific barks that
are present in the
genome and what
genome sequences they
are associated with.
So we can look at sequence
specific regulators.
We could look at a more
general epigenetic marks,
all using the same technology.
And this slide simply
recapitulates what we just
talked about over here on the
left-hand side of the board.
But we want to
know basically what
and where, in terms of
these genomic regulators,
what they are and where
they are in the genome.
And today we're going to assume
a fairly simple model, which
is that regulars that are
proximal to a gene, most
probably regulated.
Although we know in
practice, actually, it
appears that roughly one
third of the regulators that
are proximal to a gene actually
skip it and regulate a gene
further down the genome.
It's not really
understood very well
how the genome
folds in three space
to allow these transit
regulatory interactions
to occur.
But I'll just point out to
you that the simplistic model
that proximal binding
regulates proximal genes
doesn't always hold,
especially when
we get into mammals and
other higher organisms.
And as I mentioned,
another aspect of this
is that certain
proteins may need
to be modified to become
active, and thus there
are signaling pathways.
You can imagine signaling
pathways responding
to environmental stimuli
outside of cells.
These signaling
pathways can interact
with transcriptional
activators and modify
what targets they
seek in the genome.
So these sorts of
regulatory networks
will be talked
about specifically
in a separate lecture
later in the term,
but they're
extraordinarily important.
And a foundational
aspect of them
is putting together
the wiring diagram.
And the wiring diagram
has to do with where
the regulators occupy
the genome and what
genes those regulators regulate.
And in order to do
that, we're going
to utilize a
technique today called
ChIP-seq, which stands for
chromatin immunoprecipitation
followed by sequencing.
And we can now reliably
identify where regulars bind
to the genome within
roughly 10 base pairs.
So the spatial
resolution has gotten
exceptionally good with high
throughput sequencing, as we'll
see, which really is a
fantastic era to be in now,
because this really
wasn't possible 5
or even 10 years ago.
And so we now have
the tools to be
able to take apart the
regulatory occupancy
of the genome and
discern exactly
where these proteins
are binding.
The way that this is done,
as I'll describe the protocol
to you, in general, and then
I'm going to pause for a second
and see if anybody has any
questions about the specifics.
But the essential idea is that
you have a collection of cells.
Typically you need
a lot of cells.
We're talking 10 million cells.
So for certain
kinds of marks, you
can get down below a million
or even to 100,000 cells.
But to get robust signals, you
need a lot of cells at present.
And all these cells obviously
have chromosomes inside of them
with proteins that
are occupying them.
And the essential idea is that
you take a flash photography
picture of the cell
while it's alive.
You add a cross linking agent,
and that cross links proteins
creates bonds
between the proteins
and the genome, the DNA, where
those proteins are sitting.
And so you then isolate
the chromatin material,
and you wind up with pieces
of DNA with proteins occupying
them, all the proteins.
So not just some of the
proteins, but all the proteins
are non-selectively
cross-linked to the genome.
You then can take this
extract and fragment it.
Typically you fragment
it by using sonication,
which is mechanical energy,
which causes the DNA
to break at random locations.
There are more modern
techniques that we'll
touch on at the end
of today's lecture
where you could enzymatically
digest these fragments right
down to where the protein is.
But suffice to say, you get
small fragments, which you then
can immunopurify
with an antibody
to a protein of interest.
So one condition of using
this technology is either A,
you have a good
antibody to a protein
that you care about
as regulatory, or B,
you have tagged
this protein such
that it has a flag tag, myc
tag, or some other epitope
tag on it which allows
you to use an antibody
or other purification
methodology
for that specific tag.
So either you have
a good antibody
or you have a tag
on the protein.
One problem with
tags on proteins
is that they can render
the proteins nonfunctional.
If they're nonfunctional,
then, of course,
they're not going to bind
where they should bind.
And one has to be
careful about this,
because if you
introduce a tag and you
have a couple good copies of
the protein that are untagged
and one copy that
is tagged, it's
hard to tell whether or not
the tagged version is actually
doing what you think it does,
and one has to be careful.
But suffice to say,
assuming that you
have some way of
immunopurifying this protein,
you can then use the
antibodies to simply purify
those fragments that have
the protein of interest.
After you've purified
the protein of interest,
you can reverse
the cross linking,
have a collection of
fragments which you then
sequence using a high throughput
sequencing instrument.
Now recall that, in the
usually applied protocol,
the fragmentation is a random.
So you're going to be sequencing
both ends of these molecules.
For each one, you probably
only sequence one end.
You're going to sequence an
end of these molecules which
gives you a sequence tag that is
near where the event occurred,
but not exactly at it.
And we're going to
take those tags,
and if we have our
genome-- here represented
as this short, horizontal chalk
line-- we'll take our reads,
and we will align
them to the genome,
and try and discern
from those aligned
reads where the original
proteins were binding.
Now our job is to do the best
possible alignment or discovery
of where the proteins are
binding, given this evidence.
So we have a
collection of evidence
exhibited by the read sequences.
The other thing
that we will do is
we will take the original
population of molecules,
and we will sequence
them as well,
sometimes called the whole cell
extract sequence, as a control.
And we'll see why we need this
control a little bit later on.
But this is going to be
a purified so-called IP
for immunoprecipitate
fraction, which we'll sequence.
And this will be the whole
cell extract, which should not
be enriched for any
particular protein.
Now before I go on, I'd be
happy to entertain any questions
about the details
of this protocol,
because it's really important
that you feel comfortable
with it before we talk about
the computational analysis
of the output.
So if anybody has
any questions, now
would be a great time to ask.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have more of
a scientific question.
This assumes that we know
a transcriptioned factor.
Are there are ways, methods
to figure out transcription
factors so that you can design
antibodies to bind to it?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, this
assumes that we know the
regulators that we're
interested in ahead of time.
And is there a de novo
way of discovering
heretofore unknown regulators
that are binding to the genome?
The answer to that
question is sometimes,
as is usually the case.
Later in the term, we'll talk
about other methodologies
for looking at the regulatory
occupancy of the genome that
don't depend upon
immunopurification,
in which case we'll get
an understanding of what's
going on with the genome at
the level of knowing what
particular sequences are
occupied without knowing what's
there.
From the sequence,
sometimes we can
infer the family of the
protein that is sitting there.
But in general, the holy grail
of this, which has not really
fully materialized,
would be as follows,
which is instead of
purifying with an antibody
and then sequencing, why not
purify with a nucleic acid
sequence and then do mass spec,
to actually take the proteins
off of the DNA, run
them through mass spec,
and figure out what's there.
And we and others
have attempted this.
And at times, you
get good results.
But mass spec is
improving greatly,
but it's till a fraught
process with noise.
And there's a paper just
published in Nature Methods
late last year on something
called the CRAPome.
Have you heard of
this paper before?
It is all the junk you get when
you run mass spec experiments.
And so when you run a
mass spec experiment,
you can just take all the
stuff in the CRAPome out of it,
and it actually helps
you quite a bit.
That gives you an idea what the
state of the art of mass spec
is.
It's a little bit noisy.
But I think your
question is great.
I think we need to get there.
We need to get to
the place where
we can take portions
of the genome
and run them through
mass spec and figure out
what is populating it de novo
without having to know ahead
of time.
Any other questions?
OK.
Great.
So the figure on
the slide up there
also describes the
ChIP-seq protocol.
And I'll also say
that some people
believe this would never work.
They actually thought that
when you did the purification,
you would just get so
much background sequence
that when you map
it to the genome,
you could never discern
any signal whatsoever.
And so there are lively debates
about this until somebody
actually made it work,
and then the argument
was over because it made
everything else completely
and totally obsolete.
So it wasn't good to be on the
wrong side of that argument,
I'll tell you that.
I wasn't, but all right.
I was on the right side.
But suffice to say, here's
a close-up picture of Mr.
Protein-- Ms. Protein-- and what
happens when there is breakage
around that site,
followed by sequencing.
And as you can see,
the little black lines
connecting between the
protein and the DNA
is supposed to indicate
contacts sites.
And you can see the little
yellow arrows are supposed
to indicate breakage sites of
the DNA that are being caused
by, in this case, mechanical
breakage through sonication.
And you get reads from
both strands of the DNA.
Remember that a sequencing
instrument always
sequences from five
prime to three prime.
So you're going to get the
reads on the red strand
and on the blue
strand, shown here.
And when we do the
mapping, we know
which strand they're mapped on.
And the profile is
shown in the lower plot,
showing the density of
map reads versus distance
from where we believe
the protein is sitting.
And the tag density refers
to tags or sequence tags
or reads that are aligned using
the methodology we discussed
two lectures ago to the genome
we assembled last lecture.
So the characteristic
shape shown in this picture
is something that is not
the same for all proteins.
It is something that varies
from protein to protein.
And thus, one of the
things that we'll
want to do during our discovery
of where these proteins are
binding is always learn the
shape of the read distribution
that will come out of a
particular binding event.
So just to show you some
actual data, so you'll
get a feel for what
we're talking about,
this is actual data from
the Oct4 protein, which
is an embryonic regulator,
pluripotency factor,
binding to the mouse genome
around the SOCS2 gene.
And you can see the two distinct
peaks on the upper track,
both the plus strand
reads and the minus strand
reads, shown in blue
and red respectively.
Each one of the black and
white bars at the top--
probably can't be read
from the back of the room--
but each one of
those is 1,000 bases,
to give you some idea about
sort of the scale of the genome
that we're looking at here.
You can see the
SOCS2 gene below.
The exons are the solid bars.
And then you see the whole
cell extract channel,
which we talked about earlier.
And the whole cell
extract channel
is simply giving us a
background set of reads
that are nonspecific.
And so you might have a set of,
say, 10 or 20 million reads,
something like that, for when
these experiments that you map
to the genome and get a
picture that looks like this.
So now our job is to take the
read sets that we see here,
genome wide, and
figure out every place
that the Oct4 protein is
binding to the genome.
Now there are
several ways that we
could approach this question.
One way to approach
the question would
be to simply say,
where are the peaks?
And so you hear this kind of
exploration often described
as peak finding.
Where can you find the peaks?
And where is the
middle of the peak?
Now the problem
with this approach
is that it works just fine
when a peak represents
a single binding event.
So imagine that these
two fingers here
are binding events, and they're
fairly far apart of the genome.
Now as they come closer and
closer and closer together,
what will happen is that,
instead of having two peaks,
we're going to wind up
having one broad peak.
And thus, there's a
lot of biology present
in this kind of binding
of the same protein
proximal to itself.
So we need to be able to take
these sorts of events that
occur underneath a single
enrichment, or single peak,
into two separate
binding events.
And this is shown in the
next couple of slides,
right where we look at
what we would expect
from a single event, in terms
of a read enrichment profile
once it's aligned to the genome.
And we think about a
possibility that there
are two events, here
shown in indiscernible
gray and blue and red.
And we note that
each one of these
will have its own
specific profile.
And then you can consider
them to be added together
to get the peak that we observe.
Now one of the reasons this
additive property works
is that, remember, we're
working with a large population
of cells, and regulators
don't always occupy a site.
And thus, what we're looking
at in terms of the reads
are the sum of all of the
evidence from all of the cells.
And so even though the proteins
are close to one another,
we often can find
an additive effect
between that proximal binding.
So how can we handle this?
Well, what we're
going to do is we're
going to do two key
algorithmic things.
We're going to model the spatial
distribution of the reads that
come out of a specific event,
as I suggested earlier.
And we're going to keep
that model up to date.
That is, we can learn that model
by first running our method
using a common
distribution of reads,
identify a bunch
of events that we
think are bindings of a single
protein, take those events
and use them to build
a better model of what
the redistribution looks like,
and then run the algorithm
again.
And with the better
distribution,
we can do a much better
job at resolving events out
of multiple events
out of single peaks.
And the next thing
we're going to do
is we're going to model the
genome at a single base pair
level.
So we're going to consider every
single base as being the center
point of a protein binding
event, and using that model,
try and sort through how
we could have observed
the reads that we
are presented with.
And first, the spatial
distribution that we build
is going to look
something like this.
And we consider a
400 base pair window,
and we learn the
distribution of reads,
and we build an actual
empirical distribution.
We don't fit the
distribution to it,
but rather we can keep an
exact distribution or histogram
of what we observe, averaged
over many, many events.
So when we're fitting things,
we have the best possible
estimate.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was just
trying to remember
to origin of the
[INAUDIBLE] clearly.
So within the protocol,
are you sequencing
with the proteins bound
to these fragments?
PROFESSOR: No.
See, you can't do that.
You have to reverse the
cross-linking from the DNA.
And then there's
a step here which
we omitted for simplicity,
which is, we amplified the DNA.
AUDIENCE: So I was
just wondering,
if there's no protein, why
doesn't the polymerase just
read through the whole
thing from one side?
Why is there a peak?
There seems to be a
loss of signal right
where the protein is bound.
PROFESSOR: Well, that depends
upon how long the reads are
and how hard you fragment.
And in fact, that can occur.
But typically,
we're using fairly
short reads, like
35 base pair reads.
And we're fragmenting
the DNA to be,
say, perhaps 200 to
300 base pairs along.
So we're reading the first 35
base pairs of the DNA fragment,
but we're not really
all the way through.
We could read all the
way through if we wanted,
but there really wouldn't
be a point to that.
The thing that
we're observing here
is where the five prime
end of the readers, where
the leftmost edge
of the read is.
So even though it might be
reading all the way through,
we're just seeing
the left edge of it.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
Any other questions?
Yes, at the back.
AUDIENCE: So to clarify,
this distribution
that's being shown
up here on both
the positive and
negative strand--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: This is the position
of where the reads started,
not the count of the number of
times that particular base was
shown in the sequencing result.
Is that correct?
PROFESSOR: Let me
repeat the question.
What we're observing
in the distribution
is where the read starts
and not the number of times
that base shows up in
the sequencing data.
It is the number of reads
whose five prime position
start at that base.
OK So each read
only get one count.
Does that help?
OK.
The other thing that we're
going to do, for simplicity,
is we're going to assume
that the plus and the minus
strand distributions
are symmetric.
So we only learn
one distribution,
and then we flip it to
do the minus strand.
And that's shown here,
where we can articulate
this as this empirical
distribution,
where the probability or
read given a base position is
described in terms of the
distance between where we are
considering the binding
of it may have occurred
and where the read is.
So it's important for us to
look at this in some detail
so you're comfortable with it.
Here's our genome again.
And let's assume that
we have a binding
event at base m
along the genome.
And we have a read here,
r sub n, at some position.
The probability
that this read was
caused by this binding event can
be described as probably a read
n given the fact that
we're considering
an event at location m.
Now of course, it
could be that there
are other possible locations
that have caused this read.
And let us suppose
that we model all
of those positions along
the genome as a vector pi.
And each element of pi describes
the probability or the strength
of a binding event
having occurred
in a particular location.
So we can now describe the
probability of a read sub n
given pi is equal
to the summation
where i equals 1 to big
M, assuming that there
is 1 to M bases in this
genome, of a p rn given m pi m,
like this.
So we are mixing together
here all of the positions
along the genome to try
and explain this read.
So the probably of the
read, given this vector
pi, which describes all
the possible events that
could have created this
read, is this formulation,
which considers the
probability of each position
times the probability that an
event occurred at that position
subject to the constraint
that all of a pi i's sum to 1.
So we're just assigning
probability mass
along the genome from whence all
of the reads originally came.
So this is considering
a single read, r sub n,
and where that might
have originated from.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the
constraint basically state
that only one event occurred
in this fragment point?
PROFESSOR: The question
is, does this constraint
imply that only
one event occurred?
No.
The constraint is
implying that we're
going to only have one
unit of probability mass
to assign along the genome which
will generate all of the reads.
And thus, this vector
describes the contribution
of each base to the
reads that we observe.
So let us say
simplistically that it
might be that there are only
two events in the genome,
and we had a perfect solution.
Two points in the
genome, like m1 and m2,
would have 0.5 as
their values for pi.
And all the other values
in the genome would be 0.
We're going to try to make
this as sparse as possible,
as many zeroes as possible.
So only at the places in
the genome where protein
is actually binding
will pi i be nonzero.
Does that make sense?
These are great questions.
Yes.
And if people could
say their names first,
that would be great.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sara.
Just to clarify, the pi vector
is completely empirical?
PROFESSOR: This distribution
is completely empirical.
Yes, that's right, Sara,
completely empirical.
I'll also say, just so
you know, that there
are many ways of doing
this kind of discovery,
as you might imagine.
The way we're going
to describe today
was a way that was selected
as part of the ENCODE 3
pipeline for the
government's ENCODE project.
And so what I'm going
to talk about today
is the methodology that's being
used for the next set of data
for ENCODE 3 followed
by IDR analysis, which
is also part of ENCODE 3.
So what you're
hearing about today
is a pipeline that's being
used that will be published
next year as part of
the ENCODE project.
These papers, this
method's been published.
But the analysis of
all the Encyclopedia
of DNA Elements-- which
is what Encode stands
for-- the third phase of
that is utilizing this.
OK, any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the shape
of this binding event
tell you anything about the
topology of the actual protein?
PROFESSOR: It does, actually.
And we'll return to that.
But the shape of this
binding can tell you
something about the class
of protein, which is still
an area of active research.
But also note that
that is a little bit
confounded by the
fact that when you
have homotypic
binding, which means
you have these closely
spaced binding events,
you get these broader peaks.
And so there's a lot
of research into what
the shapes on the genome mean
and what biological function
of mechanism they might imply.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain pi one more time?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, explain
pi one more time, sure.
So pi is describing
where there are
binding events along the genome.
So for example, if we just had
two binding events, m1 and m2,
then pi of m1 would be
equal to 0.5, and pi of m2
would be equal to 0.5, and
all the other values of pi
would be 0.
So we're just describing with pi
where the events are occurring.
That gives us the
location of the events.
OK?
And you'll see in a moment why
we articulated it that way.
But that's what pi is doing.
Does that answer your question?
OK.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In cases
when you have two peaks
really close together,
to a point that there's
some sort of
[INAUDIBLE] between,
how do you constrain your pi?
PROFESSOR: How do
you constrain the pi
when you have
closely spaced peaks?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, you
don't constrain it.
You actually want--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, I'm
going to show you
some actual examples of
this algorithm running.
So I'm going to give you an
animation of the algorithm
running, so you can
actually watch what it does.
And you'll see, first
it's going to be something
that isn't too pleasant,
and then we'll fix it.
But the key thing
here is sparsity.
What we want to do is
we want to enforce pi
being as sparse as possible
to explain the data.
One of the common problems
in any approach to machine
learning is that, with a
suitably complex model,
you can model anything, but it's
not necessarily interpretable.
So what we want to do here is
to make pi as simple as possible
to be able to explain
the data that we see.
However, if a single event
cannot explain and observe
redistribution at a particular
point in the genome,
we'll need to bring
another event in.
All right, so that is how to
think about a single read.
And now we can just
say the probability
of our entire read set
given pi is quite simple.
It's simply the product
over all the reads.
Sorry.
Like so.
So this is the probability
of the entire read set.
So we had this
previously, which is
the probability
of a single read.
And we take the product of the
probability for each individual
read to get the likelihood
of all the reads.
So now all we need to do to
solve this problem is this.
We need to say that pi
is equal to the arg max
pi of P R pi, which gives
us the maximum likelihood
estimate for pi.
Now it's easy to
write that down, just
find the setting for
pi that maximizes
the likelihood of the observed
reads, and proof, you're done,
because now you've come up
with a pi that describes where
the binding events
are along the genome
at single base pair
solution, assuming
that pi is modeling
every single base.
Does everybody see that?
Any questions about that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: n is the
number of reads.
m is a number of
bases in the genome.
n is the number of reads.
AUDIENCE: The
length of pi, right?
Is that equal to the
number of binding events?
Or is it equal to just
the number of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The length of pi?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: It's the number
of bases in the genome,
and hopefully the
number of bindings
is much, much, much
smaller than that.
Typical number of binding
events is 5 to 30,000
across a genome that has
3 billion bases, something
like that.
So it's much, much smaller.
OK?
So this is what we
would like to solve.
And another way to look
at this model, which
it may be somewhat
more confusing,
is as follows, which is that
we have these events spread
along the genome.
And we have the reads
shown on the lower line.
And the events are
generating the reads.
So this is called
a generative model,
because the derivation
of the likelihood
directly follows from, if we
knew where the events were,
we could exactly
come up with the best
solution for the
assignment of pi,
and thus for the likelihood.
So this is what we have
on the board over here.
But we can solve this directly.
Yes.
Question in the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Eric.
I have a little question.
What is the definition
of GPS here?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
Yeah, GPS is the name
of this algorithm.
I told it to an editor
and they hated it.
But at any rate, it's called
the genome positioning system.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so you don't like
it either, right, Eric?
Oh, well.
But yes, it locates proteins
on the genome, right?
Yeah.
Good question.
So this is going to be, I
think, our first introduction
to the EM algorithm
as a way of solving
complex problems like this.
And here is the
insight we're going
to use to solve
this problem, which
is that imagine I
do the function g.
So g is going to be
this function that
tells us what reads
came from which events
and where those events
are in the genome.
So if you knew g
exactly, this would
be a really trivial
problem to solve.
It would tell you, for
every single read, which
particular binding
event caused it.
And if we knew that,
it would be great,
because then we could
say something like this.
We could say, well, we knew g.
Then the number of reeds created
by a binding event at location
m would simply be-- it's not a
very good summation sign here--
we would sum over all the reads
and count up the number of them
where read n was caused
by an event at location m.
And we just summed
up this number.
We'd have the number
of reads caused
by an event at location m.
Is everybody cool with that?
No.
Do you see the
definition of there of g
on the overhead projector?
So every time a read
n comes from event m,
that function is going
to be equal to 1.
So we just count the
number of times it's 1.
For a given location
m, we find out
how many reads came from
that event-- could be 5,
could be 10, could be 100.
We don't know exactly
how many were generated
by that particular
event, but there's
going to be some number.
And we have 10 million reads,
and we have 100,000 events,
we're going to get
about 100 reads
per event, something like that.
You can give that kind
of order of magnitude.
Everybody OK?
Any questions about
the details of this?
Because the next step is going
to be causing leaps of faith,
so I want to make sure that
everybody's on firm ground
before we take
the leap together.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you are
in forced sparsity yet?
PROFESSOR: I'm not in
forced sparsity yet.
You like sparsity.
You're going to keep
me to that, right?
So later on, you'll hold
me to it, all right?
That's your job.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's your job, all right?
Mr. Sparsity.
I like that.
He's been sparse.
I like it.
So if this is the
number of reads assigned
to a particular
location, then we
know that pi sub
m will simply be
n sub m over the summation
of all of the reads assigned
to all of the events.
And some of these
are going to be zero.
A lot of them will be zero.
So here, I don't know this
assignment of reads to events.
It's latent.
It's something I have
invented which I do not know.
But if I did know it, I'd be
able to compute pi directly,
like so, because I'd
be able to figure out
for each location on the genome
how many reads were there.
And that's how much
responsibility that location
had for generating
all of the reads.
Is everybody with me so far?
Any questions at all?
OK.
So remember, this is latent.
We don't know what it
is, but if we did know,
we'd be in great shape.
So our job now is to estimate g.
And if we could estimate
g, we can estimate pi.
And once we get a
better estimate for pi,
I'd like to suggest
to you we can
get a better estimate for g.
And we can go between
these two steps.
And so that's what the
expectation, maximization
algorithm does in the
lower part here, which
is that the left part is
estimating gamma, which
is our estimate for g, which is
looking at the number of reads
that we think are softly
assigned to a location m
over the total number
of softly assigned
reads from all locations.
And that gives the fraction of
a read at n assigned to event m.
So we are computing
an estimate of g.
But to compute this
estimate, we have to have pi.
It's telling us where we
believe that these reads are
coming from.
And once we have gamma,
which is an estimate,
we can compute pi, just in the
same way we computed it here,
if we knew g.
So we compute the expectation
of this latent function, which
we don't know, and
then we maximize
pi to maximize our likelihood.
And you can derive
this directly by taking
the log of that likelihood
probability up there
and maximizing it.
But suffice to say, you wind
up with this formulation
in the EM framework.
So I can go between these
two different steps--
the E step, the M step,
the E step, the M step.
And each time as
I go through it,
I get a better and better
approximation for pi,
until I ultimately get it
within some preset level
of convergence.
And then I'm finished.
I actually can report my pi.
But before I leave the EM
algorithm, and this formulation
of it, are there
any questions at all
about what's going on here?
Yes, question in the back.
AUDIENCE: So the solution
to the EM algorithm
doesn't always [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It gives
you a solution.
And it is the optimum solution
given the starting conditions
that we give it.
AUDIENCE: But it depends on
the starting conditions, right?
PROFESSOR: It does depend
on the starting conditions.
Any other questions?
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: Is this
dependent upon you
having discrete binding events?
So if you have a protein that
has more diffuse localization
across the genome, for
example, RNA Pol II,
would this model break down?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, does this
depend upon you having
discrete binding events?
What biological assumptions are
we making in this model about
whether or not a protein is
actually fixed and welded
to the genome in a
particular location
or whether or not
it's drifting around?
And this might be of
particular interest,
for example, if we're
looking at histones, which
are known to slide up
and down the genome,
and we're
immunoprecipitating them.
What will this give us?
We are making the
assumption that we're
dealing with proteins that have
punctate binding properties,
that actually are
point binding proteins.
And thus what we're going to
get out of this, as you'll see,
is going to be a
single location.
There are other methodologies,
which I won't describe today,
for essentially deconvolving
the motion of a protein
on the genome and coming
up with its middle
or mean position while
allowing it to move.
But today's
algorithm is designed
for point binding proteins.
Good question, OK?
All right.
So just to be clear,
what we're going to do
is we're going to
initialize everything,
such that we'll begin
by initializing pi
to be 1 over the
size of the genome.
And at the very end of this,
the strength of a binding event
will be simply the number of
reads assigned to that event
by summing up our estimate of g.
And the nice thing about this
is that because the number
of reads assigned to an
event, in some sense,
is scaled relative to
the total number of reads
in the experiment, we can
algorithmically take our genome
and chop it up into
independent pieces
and process them
all in parallel,
which is what this
methodology does.
All right.
So let's have a
look at what happens
when we run this algorithm.
So here we are.
This is synthetic data.
I have events planted at
500 and 550 base pairs.
The x-axis is between
0 and 1,400 base pairs.
And the y-axis is
pi from 0 to 1.
So here we go.
It's running.
And this is one base
pair resolution.
And it is still
running-- and stop.
Well, we get sort of a
fuzzy mess there, don't we?
And the reason we're
getting a fuzzy mess there
is that we have got a lot
of reads we've created,
and there are a lot of
different genome positions
that are claiming some
responsibility for this, which
my friend, Mr. Sparsity,
doesn't like, right?
We need to clean
this up somehow.
And let's see what
happens when we actually
look at actual data.
So here is that original
data I showed you
for the two Oct4 binding
events next to the SOCS2 gene.
And I'll run the
algorithm on these data.
And you can see it
working away here.
And once again, it's giving
us a spread of events,
and you can see
it even beginning
to fill in along where
there's noise in the genome
and stopped here.
And it's assigning the
probability mass of pi
all over the place.
It is not sparse at all.
So does anybody
have any suggestions
for how to fix this?
We've worked all might.
We've got our algorithm running.
We thought it was going
to be totally great.
When we run it, it gives us
this unfortunate, smeary kind
of result.
What could we do?
Any ideas at all?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Add a prior where
most of the reads are.
PROFESSOR: Add a prior.
You saw the word no
prior, a little tip off.
Yeah, absolutely, good point.
Add a prior.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to try and add a prior
that's going to prejudice pi
to be 0 to create sparsity.
So we like pi being 0.
So we'll add what's called
a negative Dirichlet prior,
which looks like this, which is
the probability of pi there is
proportional to 1 over pi to
the m raised to the alpha power.
And as pi gets smaller,
that gets much, much bigger.
And thus, if we add
this prior, which
happens to be a very
convenient prior to use,
we can force pi to
be 0 in many cases.
And when we take that prior
into account and we compute
the maximum a posteriori
values for pi,
the update rules
are very similar,
except that what's
interesting is
that the rule on the left for
computing our estimate of g
is identical.
But on the right, what we do
is we take the number of reads
that we observe at a
particular location
and we subtract
alpha from it, which
was that exponent in our prior.
And what that simply means is
that if you don't have alpha
reads, you're history.
You're going to get eliminated.
So this is going to do something
called component elimination.
If you don't have
enough strength,
you're going to
get zapped to zero.
Now you don't want to do this
too aggressively early on.
You want to let things sort
of percolate for a while.
So what this algorithm does
is it doesn't eliminate
all of the components that don't
have alpha reads at the outset.
It lets it run for
a little while.
But it provides you with a way
of ensuring that components
get eliminated and set to zero
when they actually don't have
enough support in the read set.
So once again, all
we're going to do
is we're going to add this prior
on pi, which we will wind up
multiplying times
that top equation.
We'll get the joint probability
of r and pi in this case,
and then we're going to maximize
it using this EM adaptation.
And when we do so,
let me show you
what happens to our first
example that we had.
OK, that's much cleaner, right?
We actually only have
two events popping out
of this at the right locations.
All right.
So that's looking good.
And the probability is
summed to 1, which we like.
And then we'll run
this on the Oct4 data.
And you can see now,
instead of getting
the mushing around
those locations, what's
going to happen is that
most of the probability mass
is going to be absorbed into
just a couple components
around those binding events.
Now another way to test this
is to ask whether or not,
if we looked at what we
believe are closely spaced
homotypic events, in this case,
for CTCF, with that prior,
we still can recover
those two events being
next to each other
in the genome.
And so if we run this, you
can see it running along here.
Each one of these iterations,
by the way, is an EM step.
And there you go.
And you can see that
even from the sparse data
you see above-- that's the
actual data being used,
all those little bars
up there, read counts
for the five prime ends of
the reads-- we can recover
the position of
those binding events.
Question, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It depends
upon the number of reads,
but it's somewhere
around three or four.
I mean, if you look at the
GPS paper, which I posted,
it tells you how alpha is set.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you use
wholesale extract data
when you are trying to compute?
PROFESSOR: Question, do we
use wholesale extract data?
I told you all how
important it was,
and I haven't
mentioned it again.
We're about to get to that,
because that's very important.
I'm glad you asked
that question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It looks like,
along the genome coordinates,
each event is only
one base pare,
but binding is usually
more than one base pair.
So is that the center
of the binding?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well, it's the center of the
read distribution function.
Whether or not it's the center
of the binding of the protein,
I really can't tell.
OK, great.
And I'll just point out
that a power of this method
is its ability to take
apart piles of reads
like this and to these so-called
homotypic binding events, where
you can see where the motif is.
And you can see this method will
take apart that pile of reads
into two independent events,
whereas other popular methods,
of which there are
many for analyzing
these type of ChIP-seq
data, don't take apart
the event into multiple
events, because most of them
make the assumption
that one pile of reads
equals one binding event.
Now back to our question
about wholesale extract.
What happens if you get to
a part of the genome that
looks like this?
We're going to go
back to our Oct4 data.
And we have our Oct4 IP
track, which is above,
and then our wholesale
extract tract
is down there on the bottom.
What would you say?
Would you say those are
really Oct4 binding events?
Or do you think something
else is going on there?
If so, what might it be?
Any ideas about
what's going on here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Regions with a lot
of repeats in the genome?
PROFESSOR: Regions with
repeats in the genome?
Yes.
In fact, you can see repeats
annotated in green right there.
And as you recall from last time
when we talked about assembly,
it's very difficult
to actually get
the number of repeat
elements correct.
And a consequence of that
is if you underestimate
the number of repeat
elements in the genome
and you collapse them, when
you do sequencing of the genome
and you remap it, you're going
to get regions of the genome
were a lot of reads pile
up, because they're actually
coming from many different
places in the genome,
but they only have
one place to align.
And these towers of
reads, as they're called,
can create all
sorts of artifacts.
So in order to judge the
significant of events,
what we'll do is a
two-step process.
First, we will run
our discovery pipeline
and discover where all the
events are in the IP channel
without regard to the
wholesale extract channel,
in this particular case.
And then we will
filter the events
and say which of the events
are real in view of the data
from the wholesale
extract channel.
And so the way to
represent this is
what is the likelihood we
would have seen those IP reads
at random given the
wholesale extract channel?
So how can we
formulate this problem?
Well imagine that we
take all of the reads
that we see in both channels
and we add them together.
So we get a total
number of reads
at a particular
location in the genome.
If, in fact, they were
going to occur at random,
we'd be doing a coin flip.
Some reads will go
on the IP channel.
Some reads will go on the
wholesale extract channel.
So now we can ask what's the
probability we observed greater
than a certain number of
reads on the IP channel
at chance, assuming a
coin flipping model where
we've added the reads together.
Another way to view that is
what's the chance that we have
observed less than
a certain number of
reads in the wholesale
extract channel
assuming a coin flipping model?
And that will give us a p-value
under the null hypothesis
that, in fact, there
is no binding event
and simply what's
going on is that we
have reads being flipped
between the two channels out
of a pool of the
total number of reads.
And if we take that
approach, we can formulate it
as the binomial in
the following way.
We can compute a p-value for
a given binding event using
the data from both
the IP channel
and from the control channel.
And the way that we do this is
that we look at the number of
reads assigned to an
event, because we already
know that number.
We've computed that number.
And we take a similar window
around the control channel.
We count the number
of reads in it
and ask whether or not the
reads in the IP channel
is significantly larger enough
than the reads in the control
channel to reject the null
hypothesis that, in fact, they
occurred at random.
So this is the way that
we compute the p-values
for events.
So once we've computed
the p-values for events,
we still have our multiple
hypothesis correction problem,
which is that if we
have 100,000 events,
we need to set our p-value's
cut off and appropriate value.
And I think that
you may have heard
about this before in recitation.
But the way that this
is done in this system
is to use a
Benjamini-Hochberg correction.
And the essential idea is that
we take all of the p-values
and we organize them
from smallest to largest.
And we're going to take
a set of the top events,
say 1 through 4, and
call them significant.
And we call them significant
under the constraint
that p-value sub i is less
than or equal to i over n,
where n is the total number
of events times alpha,
which is our desired
false discovery rate.
So this allows us
in a principled way
to select the events
that we believe
are significant up to a false
discovery rate, which might be,
for example, 0.05 for
something that's typically
used for a false discovery rate.
So we've talked about
how to discover events,
how to judge their
significance individually,
how to take a ranked list of
events from a given experiment
and determine which
ones are significant
up to a desired
false discovery rate.
The false discovery
means that, let's say,
that we have 1,000
events that come out.
If this false
discovery rate was 0.1,
we would expect 100 of
them to be false positives.
So it's the fraction
of positives
that we detect that we
think are going to be false.
And we can set that to
be whatever we want.
Now let's talk about the
analysis of these sort of data.
There's a question up here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this randomness,
does that correct to the fact
that in your previous slide the
coin isn't necessarily fair?
PROFESSOR: Oh, the
null hypothesis
assumed that the coin was fair,
that reads could either occur.
That in this case, for
example, that the reads were
either occurring in the control
channel or in the IP channel
with equal likelihood, assuming
because they were coming
from the same process, which was
not related to the IP itself.
They're coming from some
underlying noise process.
AUDIENCE: So typically
you'd have some fixed number
of reads, and so in the IP
channel, the bulk of your reads
was in your peaks.
Then you would have
fewer in your--
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, how do you
normalize for the
number of reads
and how they're being spent?
Because in the IP
channel, you're
spending the reeds on
IP enriched events.
In the wholesale
extract channel,
you're not spending
the reads on those,
so you have more reads to
go around for bad things,
so to speak.
So what this algorithm
does-- which I'm glad
you brought it up-- is it takes
regions of the genome that
are event free, and it matches
them up against one another
and fits a model
against them to be
able to scale the control reads
so that the number of reads
in the IP and
extract channel are
the same in the regions
that are free of events.
And so it matches
things, so it is 0.5.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Even if wasn't
0.5, wouldn't this rank list
correct with that?
PROFESSOR: No, it would not.
Let us suppose that we
made a horrible mistake
and that we let
these events through
because our p was wrong.
They would have a very
large number of reads,
and they would be
very significant.
As a consequence,
they would float up
to the top of this list
as having the lowest
p-values, or the
most significant,
and they would pop through this.
So we would report
them as binding events,
which is not desirable.
These are all great questions.
Any other questions at all?
So we've talked about this.
The next question you
might have would be,
you've done two replicates
of the same chip.
You always want to do two of
every experiment, if not three
or four.
And I know it's
expensive, but you
don't know where you are if
you only do one of something.
Trust me.
So assuming you've done
two experiments that
were identical ChIP
experiments, and you
would like to know
whether or not
the results between those two
experiments are concordant.
How might you go about
determining this?
Does anybody have any ideas?
Let me suggest something to you.
Imagine that we
create two lists-- one
for experiment x and
one for experiment y.
And we're going to
put in this list,
in rank order, the
strongest events
and where they
occur in the genome.
And let us suppose that we
are able to match events
across experiments when
they're in the same location.
So what we'll do is we'll
say Event one occurs here.
Event 13 occurs here and here.
Event 9 occurs here and here.
Event 10 is matched.
Event 11 occurs here.
Event 57 occurs here.
And these are ranked in
order of significance.
They're not
completely concordant,
and they're ranked according
to the significance
in this particular experiment
and this particular experiment.
And we would like to
know whether or not
we think these two
experiments are
good replicates of one another.
Now the nice thing
about converting this
into a rank test is
that we are no longer
sensitive to the number of reads
or any specific numeric values
represented by each
one of these events.
We're simply ranking them
in terms of their importance
and asking whether or not they
appear to be quite similar.
So one way to do this is simply
to take a rank correlation,
which is a correlation between
the ranks of identical events
in the two lists.
And so, for example, imagine
in the lower right-hand corner
of this slide shows you an
example of X and Y values,
although there's not really
a linear relationship
between them, and the Pearson
correlation coefficient
is 0.88.
If we look at the right
correlation, which
is defined by the equation
on the left, which is really
simply the correlation
between their rank values,
the Spearman correlation
for rank is 1.
They're perfectly matched.
So if you want to
consider whether or not
two experiments
are very similar,
I'd suggest you consider
rank based tests.
But we can do even
more than this.
Imagine that we
would like to know
at what point along
this list things
are no longer concordant,
that we would like to consider
all the events that are
consistent among these two
experiments.
And we assume that there is
a portion of the experiment
results that are concordant
and part that is discordant.
And we want to learn
where the boundary is.
So what we'll do is this.
We will look at the number of
events that are concordant up
to a particular point.
Let's see here, make sure we
get the parametrization right.
So if we have lists that
are n long, psi of n of t
is the number of
events that are paired
in the top n times t events.
So t is simply the fraction.
If is 0.25, that would
mean that in the top 25%
of the events, the number
of events that are paired.
Actually, it's the
fraction of events.
Sorry.
So assuming that we had perfect
replicates, what we would see
would be that psi of n of
t would look like this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is t?
PROFESSOR: t is the
fraction of the events
that we're considering.
So this t might
be equal to 0.25.
If this was 10, then this
would be-- oh, sorry.
I think this t equal 0.5.
If n was equal to 10, this
would be the first five events.
So t is the fraction.
n is the total number of events.
So if this is t, which
is the fraction which
goes from 0 to 1, and
this is psi of n of t,
this would be a perfectly
matched set of replicates.
A 0.5, 0.5 of the events are
matched, which is perfect.
Can't do any better than that.
So this is simply
telling us, as we
take larger and larger
fractions of our event, what
fraction of them are
matched up to that point?
Question.
AUDIENCE: So this assumes
that the rank order
is important for the
correlation, right?
The higher rank
they are, we expect
them to be better correlated.
For example, if
in the middle they
were the best correlated, but
not the top or bottom in terms
of the ranking, then you
might have a weird looking--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The question is,
doesn't this assume
that we care most
about the events
up here, as opposed to
the events, for example,
in the middle.
And this analysis
is done to consider
how many of the
top events we take
that we think are consistent
across replicates.
So it starts at the top as a
consequence of that assumption.
This is the definition
of psi n, which
is the fraction of
the top events that
are paired in the top events.
It's roughly linear
from the point
where events are no
longer reproducible.
And psi prime of n is the
derivative of that function.
And graphically, if
we look at these,
we can see that there's
perfect correspondence
on the left point
up to some point.
And then the hypothesis of this
irreproducible discovery rate
is at that point things
stop being in correspondence
because you've hit the noise
part of the event population.
and you get to junk.
And as soon as you get to
junk, things fall apart.
And what this
methodology does is
it attempts to fit the
distribution to both
the correspondence and the
non-correspondence parts
of the population, and you
get to set a parameter, which
is the probability that you're
willing to accept something
that's part of the
junk population
of the non-correspondence
population.
And the way this is used, for
example, in the ENCODE project
is that all ChIP-seq experiments
are done in parallel.
Event discovery is done
independently on them.
All of the events from
each independent experiment
are ranked from 1 to n.
And then IDR is
done on the results
to figure out
which of the events
are consistent
across replicates.
And obviously, if you've
had a very bad replicate,
you get a very small number
of events, if any at all.
But if you have good
replicates, then you
get a large number of events.
A secondary question is, imagine
you had processing algorithm A
and processing algorithm B.
It might be that processing
algorithm A typically
gave you more reproducible
events than processing algorithm
B, that whenever you ran A,
you could get much
further down this curve
before things fell apart.
Does that mean that A is
necessarily better, or not?
What do you think?
Would you always pick algorithm
A if that was the case?
Any insight on this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: No, probably,
because there's
experimental
considerations to it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I would go with [INAUDIBLE]
experimental considerations.
But the reason
you might not pick
it is it might be that if
algorithm A always gave you
the same wrong answers
in the same order,
it would score perfectly
on this, right?
It doesn't mean that it's right.
It just means it's consistent.
So for example, it could
be calling all the towers
as events, and it
could always give you,
for every experiment,
the same results.
In fact, one
interesting thing to do
is to run this kind of analysis
against your experiment,
and an outlier shouldn't
match your experiment.
It should fail.
It's always good to
run negative controls
when you're doing data analysis.
So this IDR analysis
simply allows
you to pick alpha, which is
the probability of the rate
of repairs for the
irreproducible part
of the mixture that
you're willing to accept.
And the way this is
used is, as I said,
is that here you see
different ways of analyzing
ChIP-seq data.
And the little
vertical tick mark
indicates how many
peaks they get
before they can't go
any further because they
hit the IDR bound alpha.
And some methodologies can
produce far more events
consistently than
other methods can.
So that's just something
for you to keep in mind.
And I will not have time to
present all the rest of this.
But I did want to point
out one thing to you, which
is that the methodology
we talked about today
is able to resolve
where things are
in the genome at exceptional
spatial resolution,
within 20 base
pairs genome wide.
And it's always run genome wide
at single base pair solution.
And it can do
things like compute
for pairs of
transcription factors
that have been profiled
using ChIP-seq,
the spacing between them for
spacings that are significant.
And so you can see
that we're beginning
to understand the regulatory
grammar of the genome in terms
of the way factors
organize together
and they interact to implement
the combinatorial switches
that' we've talked about.
That's it for today.
You guys have been
totally great.
We'll see you on
Tuesday for RNA-seq.
And have a great
weekend until then.